Let's consider a problem where I throw the ball with an initial velocity of 50 m/s.
But this time I don't say V₀x or V₀y,
because this is not purely horizontal or purely vertical. It's at an angle.
Now, we know if we can break this problem into two 1-dimensional motion problems we're all set.
So, that's should be our end goal.
Let's pause for a second. Not literally. Don't hit the pause button.
But let's think back to when we first started talking about horizontal and vertical velocity.
Remember how we talked about a ball with vertical and horizontal velocity components?
Well, these components were just a way of thinking about the true velocity,
which was off at some angle.
In that case, we went from components to the true velocity.
Now, we're going to go the other way.
What do I mean by that?
I mean, we're going to make a right triangle. How do we do it?
Well, here's our angled side. Here's our hypotenuse.
Now, I've broken this hypotenuse down into what I call components--
a horizontal and a vertical initial velocity component.
Now, if I call this angle α, and I tell you that α is equal to about 53 degrees,
can you tell me what V₀y equals?
You might have to think back to the trigonometry from unit 1.
Enter your answer here and round to the nearest whole number.